Hey guys,
Why is discipline
so important, so crucial in a man's life?
Because if you don't have self-control,
what makes you different from an animal that
only lives according to its urges and desires?
Wise men are extremely disciplined
in every aspect of their lives,
because they understand that they need
to sacrifice temporary things and wants,
desires, you know, in order to
achieve what they want most in life.
[Hebrews 12:11]
You know, your feelings, your
emotions, are good to have.
You know, on one end, but on the
other end it's like a two-edged sword.
You know, because it can cut inward as well.
It can give you joy and those kind of feelings,
but, when it cuts inward you
know it can make you crave
things that you know are actually
not good for you in the long term.
And that's where discipline comes in.
For example, you might not feel like
studying now to become a doctor
later which is what you really want.
Or, you might not feel like eating healthy
and working out now to get a good body later.
But that is what you really want.
So, you discipline yourself in every
area of your life, especially when you know
those times where you experience temporary
things that you don't really want to do.
You feel it in your shoulder, like man,
I don't really want to do this.
I don't feel like it.
But you do it anyway, you sacrifice
that part of your life, right?
You're like - man - I'm going to do what
needs to be done even if I don't like it.
I'm going to endure it so that I can go through
this part of my life that's temporary and achieve
that which - what I want most in my life.
So you need to discipline yourself,
to have self-control.
Paul said:
[1 Corinthians 9:24-27]
Now, how can you be more disciplined?
You probably think - well - I have to
do this and this and this and this
and that's where you're wrong.
It's not about you.
You have to do nothing.
Let me explain.
You have to do
nothing in your own little human power because by
yourself, on your own, you can accomplish nothing.
You cannot have effective 100 percent self-control
in every aspect of your life if you try to do it
by yourself, because you are the problem.
Jesus said:
[John 15:5]
Do you get it?
One of the fruits of the Spirit is self-control.
So if you live through the Spirit - the power
of the Holy Spirit - then you will be
able to produce the fruit of the Spirit
and one of them is self-control.
And this is not your own power,
on your soul level.
It is a spiritual power.
[Galatians 5:22-23]
So, if you're a reborn Christian and you
say, well, I don't have self-control,
then in a sense, you're right, because
we all have that sinful fleshly nature
within us and it's going to be there until
the day we die and it pushes us to do sin.
Like overeating - gluttony -
getting angry - and quarrel.
Or not study but be lazy.
It is that fleshly nature
within you that brings you down.
But you see, if you are a true reborn Christian,
you have received a new spiritual nature.
God Himself, the Holy Spirit,
came and lives inside of you.
You see, there is a change.
And now, you can choose to live through the
Spirit, and the Spirit can overcome the flesh.
And it is the only power that can overcome the
sinful nature because you cannot overcome it.
Because it is in you.
You are the problem.
It is your emotions.
It is your desires that is
pushing you to do things that you don't
really want to do and later you regret.
And you're like, man, why did I do this?
Is because of the sinful nature within you.
And some people, they get frustrated,
they get angry, you know, and sad.
Because, man, they don't
understand themselves anymore.
Why do they keep on doing
things which they regret later?
And it seems like they
can't have any self-control.
Some even get afraid because
they don't know what to do.
[2 Timothy 1:7]
If you want to be more disciplined - if you do it
on your your own little human power - that level
just on your soul level - you know you can try to
do it to some degree, but you will always reach
that area where you're stuck.
But you can do it through
the Spirit that is in you.
So if you want to learn how to
discipline yourself, grow in Christ.
He is the answer.
Living through the Spirit.
That is the key.
When you start growing in Christ, you learn truth.
You start to understand the truth.
You write it on your heart.
You start to live it, and then everything changes.
Especially having self-discipline,
because now you're not on your own.
You're not struggling through life.
You understand a bigger picture of life.
You open the tap to let the
power of God flow through you.
The Holy Spirit.
And you just follow him.
[Philippians 4:13]
You know, certain people ask me sometimes,
Daniel, how are you so determined?
You know, how do you have self-control?
Well, it's not me.
It's all because of God.
When I was younger I struggled
with self-discipline, believe it or
not, until God revealed Himself to me.
I accepted Him as Lord and Savior.
And then I started to grow spiritually.
Jesus also talks about those of little faith.
But you can grow in your faith and
that is what makes you stronger.
It is God that teaches us how to
have self-discipline, to control our thoughts,
to take all those thoughts captive, you know,
and bring it under the Lordship of Jesus Christ.
It is He that helped me to control my
thoughts - my body - my actions - everything.
And He can help you too if you ask Him.
[Proverbs 12:1]
Now, if you want to understand this more,
especially the difference of living
through the Spirit and not the flesh,
then please get my free eBook I'll add it
for you in the video description down below.
And then you can also watch these videos here.
And before you go, always remember, life is short,
so don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.